we've discussed the sentencing of Donald
Trump's personal attorney Michael Cohen
- three years in prison we talked about
that at the top of the show there's a
funny little sidebar story - the Cohen
sentencing which involves Fox News host
Sean Hannity we learned during the
Michael Cohen fiasco that Sean Hannity
had a relationship with Michael Cohen
initially Cohen said he represented Sean
Hannity we learned that Cohen had only
three clients Donald Trump Hannity and
one other party that I can't remember
offhand Hannity denied it saying no no
no Cohen never formally represented me
but I would sometimes bring him legal
legal questions where I just wanted like
his general opinion on some kind of
informal basis but in court cohen
revealed that hannity was a client of
his so i tend to believe that Hannity's
the one lying about this the point is
Hannity liked Cohen at some point
candidate Hannity knows Cohen and
Hannity has on at least an informal
basis if not more formal sought legal
advice from Michael Cohen there were
numerous stories that Hannity did on his
show about Michael Cohen where he didn't
make any mention of the fact that he is
interviewing someone or talking about
someone who has given him legal advice
who he has a legal relationship with so
there's a connection there that would be
relevant to his commentary about Cohen
he never made that clear just hours
before Michael Cohen was since then
sentenced to three years in prison
yesterday sean hannity was caught
deleting a bunch of tweets related to
michael cohen hannity deleted close to
300 tweets
including at least five specifically
related to michael cohen of course we
still have access to these
some examples include that infamous
denial that sean hannity made of michael
Cohen's representation of him saying
quote Michael Cohen has never
represented me in any matter
I never retained him received an invoice
or paid legal fees I have occasionally
had brief discussions with him about
legal questions about which I wanted his
input and perspective now of course look
at the language being used their right
eye he never represented me in a matter
well that has a specific legal meaning I
never retained him okay I never received
an invoice I never paid
legal fees well what if it was Hannity's
business partner who did or what if it
was a shell company controlled by
Hannity for his real estate holdings
which paid Michael Cohen
we just don't know my point is we can't
glean anything from this tweet about the
spirit of the relationship but that
tweet has since been deleted by Sean
Hannity another example of a deleted
tweet from Hannity dan bond Geno and
Rick Unger joined me next to debate the
media's coverage of the raid on Michael
Cohen's office why delete that one well
that was a segment during which the
entire investigation of Michael Cohen
was written off as politically motivated
nonsense not a great tweet once the
guy's been sentenced to three years in
prison now a counter-argument that I've
seen floating around Pat is David he
deleted like more than 250 tweets only
five had to do with Cohen this isn't
about deleting tweets that have anything
to do with Cohen he's just deleting old
tweets give me a break
Hannity is smart enough to realize Pat
that if you don't want it to seem like
the point is to delete tweets about
Cohen even though you did it as his
sentencing was going on you also delete
of a bunch of other tweets that are
relatively innocuous that's it that's a
known method yeah and you got to give
them a little bit of credit because it's
somewhat clever instead of just deleting
the tweets having to do with Michael
Cohen you also delete some 100-200
innocuous ones I like it it's a good
strategy yeah it's a it's an obvious
strategy but it is one that other people
have also employed now I want to go back
to the content of one of these tweets
Sean Hannity's net worth is reportedly
in the hundreds of millions or close to
a hundred million it's an insane amount
of money his salary is by some accounts
more than twenty five million dollars a
year
why is he lot and running legal
questions by Michael Cohen like whether
it's on a formal or informal basis isn't
it a little weird that Hannity is even
going to Cohen for advice does that not
suggest that there may be more to this
relationship than simply Hannity finds
Cohen to be a competent attorney yeah
didn't at one point Hannity said he said
that um like maybe he gave Cohen ten
bucks
a party sometime if you're worth like
tens of millions of dollars what is ten
dollars to you that's just not a
transaction that would happen among two
rich folks it's a very very strange
thing and I think that there is much
more to it and in any case the entire
apparatus is in panic here I was talking
to a friend who works in media in
Washington DC yesterday and she told me
that she's been talking to people behind
the scenes and they are in full panic
about how much do you want to distance
yourself from what's going on but at the
same time you don't want to go so crazy
distancing yourself that you draw more
attention to yourself if that makes
sense and a lot of people are sort of in
that situation right now and I don't
have advice for them my advice would
have been not to have become involved in
the first place today's program
sponsored in part by blinkers comm slash
Pakman I've talked about blinkers before
it's this awesome app that I've been
using for several months now and what it
does is take the best and most
critically acclaimed non-fiction books
and condenses them into 15-minute
audiobooks that you can listen to in one
sitting
you could listen to ten books in an
afternoon I know that many in our
audience want to expand their horizons
and learn more about all sorts of
different topics but we're mostly
limited by time to some degree I know
I'm not able to read all of the books
that I want simply because I've got
other stuff going on and that's why
blink is - such a great tool you can
absorb the most important information
and insights from the book in one
sitting and our audience can get a seven
day free trial by going to blink is calm
slash Pakman if you're watching on
youtube click the link in the video
description and after that free trial if
you like blinka stand i think you are
going to like it you can continue
enjoying thousands of condensed
audiobooks for about five bucks a month
go to be li NK is t.com slash PA k ma n